[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour un nouveau
numéro du 7-8 lipdo au sommaire ce
vendredi 19 juin les cinémas vont enfin
pouvoir accueillir de nouveau leur
public mais les conditions sanitaires
restent strictes nous avons suivi leurs
préparations pour la réouverture du 22
juin depuis deux semaines la police
manifeste sa colère dans toute la france
dans les yvelines aussi des
rassemblements et j'ai de menottes non
lieu nous en discuterons avec julien le
cam secrétaire régional du syndicat de
police alliance le retour à l'école pour
tous les élèves qui se prépare doucement
les soignants mobiliser pour défendre
l'hôpital public et un nouveau président
de le pays nous reviendrons sur ce qui a
marqué l'actualité de cette semaine dans
les événements je vous le disais en
titre plus que quelques jours à attendre
pour les cinéphiles les salles obscures
vont pouvoir ouvrir à partir du 22 juin
à condition de respecter certaines
mesures sanitaires patrick jacques de
dixmude et or ils eurent mons sont allés
voir comment certaines salles
saint-quentinoise se préparer à
accueillir le public
ils ont temporairement pris la place des
confiseries et du pop corn
ces produits d'hygiène sont désormais
les nouveaux alliés du directeur du ciné
7 à elancourt autorisée à rouvrir à
partir du 22 juin les salles obscures
sont soumises un protocole strict si le
port du masque est recommandé pour le
public
il faut néanmoins respecter un siège
d'écart entre chaque groupe
on a décidé que avant chaque début de
séance on irait faire un tour masqués
dans les salles pour vérifier que tout
va bien
voilà et on espère que ce sera bon
enfant et que tout ira bien qu'on n'aura
pas intervenir l'établissement est lent
courtois fait le choix de ne pas mettre
en place de réservation par internet
la billetterie se fera donc sur place en
respectant une file d'attenté unique et
les distance adéquate
nous avons ici des gens qui sont des
passionnés depuis parfois 30 ou 40 ans
qui sont des abonnés qui sont de
fervents admirateurs mes supporters du
cinéma sont pas des clients sont des
supporters nous ont multiplié les
messages entre autres sur les réseaux
sociaux pour demander qu'on rouvre est
une reprise progressive également pour
le multiplexe ugc ciné cité à skywest
les seize salles rouvriront à partir du
22 juin à 16 heures avec une contrainte
comme partout ailleurs la capacité
diminuée de moitié
les salles seront également à errer
entre chaque séance les interférences
sont beaucoup plus importante
qu'auparavant donc entre chaque film il
y aura quasiment à minima une demi heure
entre chaque séance pour que les gens
qui sortent ne croise pas forcément les
gens qui rentrent dans la salle
concernant la programmation aucune
grosse sortie n'est prévue pour la
semaine de reprise on a décidé de
relancer les incontournables j'ai c'est
qu'ils sont les meilleurs films de
l'année 2019 donc ça on va le programmer
pendant une quinzaine de jours à 3 euros
l'occasion donc de voir ou de revoir
pendant les premières semaines de
réouverture le champ du loup hors norme
ou encore les misérables
une séance spéciale est prévue le
dimanche 12 juillet pour découvrir une
nouveauté tout simplement noir en
présence de l'équipe du film
[Musique]
depuis deux semaines on observe de
nombreuses images de policiers jetant
leurs menottes en signe de protestation
et mécontentement envers leurs ministres
ainsi que des mobilisations souvent
nocturnes
le climat est particulièrement tendue
entre les affaires de racisme devient
messageries et réseaux sociaux et celle
de violences policières dans les
yvelines 150 fonctionnaires de police se
sont revenus lundi devant le
commissariat de versailles
je viens le cam secrétaire général
régional d evelyne deux syndicats de
police alliance et en communication avec
nous bonjour bonjour alors vous étiez
lundi avec vos collègues que souhaitiez
vous dénoncez tout d'abord le ras-le-bol
s'est s'était incliné lundi un véritable
ras-le-bol suite aux propos tenus par
notre ministre un qui a qui a carrément
lâché notre profession a lâché mes
collègues et lundi on voulait justement
montrer notre mécontentement et notre
ras-le-bol à travers cette opération se
jeter de menottes devant le commissariat
de versailles à vous demander même le
départ du ministre qui streiff
christophe casanave de steam et qu'il
gère mal la situation
pas tout à fait il l'a lâché
littéralement la profession notre
secrétariat général et notre secrétaire
général
alliance police nationale demandent à
rencontrer le président de la république
pour justement évoqué le malaise de la
profession et faire part notamment de
toutes nos revendications parce que on a
un cahier de revendications important
est justement j'avais demandé si vous
aviez vu des réponses depuis la
manifestation de lundi des retours alors
nous avons obtenu des rendez vous auprès
du dgpn il ya deux rendez vous de prévu
le 30 juin et le 3 juillet et je sais
que nous sommes toujours en attente de
rencontrer le président de la république
alors vous me disiez vous aviez beaucoup
de revendications quelle est la
situation actuelle dans la police il ya
un grand malaise vous pouvez vous en
rendre compte lundi en plus en plus de
mes collègues de la sécurité publique on
pouvait les voir aussi mes collègues de
la police judiciaire qui sont joints à
nous ce qui est plutôt rare et qui
montre qu'il ya un vrai ras-le-bol
généralisé dans la profession il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de revendications 1
qui restent sans réponse
et justement on souhaiterait faire le
point avec
dgpn notamment sur la réforme du
management les conditions de travail les
conditions du travailleur de nuit le
manque d'effectif le manque de moyens
qui est criant et notamment dans les
yvelines et comment vous l'expliquez ce
malaise
justement si vous voulez il ya eu
beaucoup de réformes de fait on a fait
beaucoup d'économies dans la profession
en plus d'être lâché par notre ministre
de l'intérieur on peut parler d'un d'un
laxisme judiciaire qui crée un sentiment
d'impunité parmi les délinquants et le
département a été en proie durant le
confinement à plusieurs semaines de
violences urbaines et d' acte très
violent on voit encore un dimanche
dernier dimanche soir dernier à houilles
un an des règlements de comptes entre
bandes à coups de machette
donc il faut savoir que le département
est un département malheureusement trop
lent et le ministère de l'intérieur fait
des économies d'effectifs alors qu'ils
devraient au contraire en injecter on a
injecté plus alors parmi les annonces de
christophe castaner il ya plusieurs
mesures comme la fin de la technique et
de l'étranglement vous l'avez dit avec
le taser comme alternative la suspension
systématique pour chaque soupçon d'acte
raciste avéré et encore une réforme de
l'igpn
vous en avez parlé de l'igpn cette
réforme est ce qu'elle serait la clé
finalement pour établir une forme de
confiance entre police citoyens même
vous avec votre hiérarchie
si vous voulez nous les l'igpn nous mes
collègues
voilà quand ils sont amenés à y aller
s'ils présentent un voile à ccc des
actes de procédure on va dire pas
habituel et nous c'est qu'on n'est pas
vrai on sur cette amende à nous si vous
voulez quand on entend le ministre de
l'intérieur parce parler de soude sont
avérées présumés enfin c'est quelque
chose de ridicule
il stigmatise l'ensemble de la
profession il faut savoir que les
fonctionnaires de police font partie de
la catégorie des fonctionnaires les plus
sanctionnées déjà en france et je peux
vous dire que malheureusement au moindre
écart
justement les les sanctions tombent nous
2019 qui montre que le nom d' enquête a
augmenté mais que le nombre de sanctions
a quand même diminué
oui alors ça
s'ils voulaient nous sur le sur le
département on est loin d'un peu tout ça
il faut savoir que nous ce que l'on
demande dans un premier temps c'est
d'eux que mes collègues et cette
présomption d'innocence parce que quand
on entend le ministre parlait on a
l'impression que mes collègues sont
systématiquement coupable et ne peuvent
pas bénéficier cette présomption
d'innocence après les et enquêtes sont
diligentées par l'igpn ou même des fois
par la direction départementale et je
peux vous dire que quand mes collègues
sont sont mises en cause de son
bourdonnement sanctionné malheureusement
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de passe-droit pour notre
profession
au contraire on est une profession très
surveillé très sanctionnés et justement
à travers les propos aussi de monsieur
castanet on a l'impression d'une
stigmatisation de l'ensemble de la
profession qui est pas acquis à la
normale pour conclure cet entretien est
ce que vous prévoyez d'autres
mobilisations
oui alors pour l'instant effectivement
il hier soir on a eu un rassemblement du
côté de sartrouville donc pour l'instant
la colère ne retombe pas parce qu'on n'a
pas d' annonce encore vraiment concrètes
et mes collègues attendent beaucoup
parce qu'il ya un vrai ras-le-bol et
notamment dans les yvelines
parce qu'il faut savoir que mes
collègues ont été durement touchés et
mobiliser également durant la période du
coc vie 19 coups ils ont été en première
ligne pour comment faire gérer la le
confinement et si vous voulez mes
collègues attendent beaucoup
et s'il faut continuer à mobiliser nos
francs merci je viens le quément d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
je le rappelle vous êtes secrétaire
régional des yvelines du syndicat de
police alliance
[Musique]
tous les élèves de retour à l'école le
22 juin c'était l'une des annonces des
manuels macron lors de sa dernière
allocution présidentielle dimanche soir
cette semaine les écoles et collèges
étaient en attente de nouveaux
protocoles sanitaires assoupli bien sûr
mais non sans inquiétude nouveaux résume
cette semaine de préparation
dès lundi la rectrice de l'académie de
versailles s'est rendu dans une école de
vélizy villacoublay pour expliquer les
premières grandes lignes du nouveau
protocole sanitaire allégée en vue d'une
réouverture des écoles et collèges total
le 22 juin le protocole sanitaire va
être allégé à partir du 22 juin cela
signifie que au lieu d'avoir au moins un
mètre entre chaque bureau il y aura un
mètre entre chaque élève dans cette
école primaire environ la moitié des
élèves a pu retrouver les salles de
classe au grand bonheur des enfants
je suis contente parce que ça faisait
deux mois et du coup on a pu retrouver
les amis retrouver l'école et la
maîtresse du pauwels neutre mais alors
tous les élèves pourront ils vraiment
reprendre le 22 juin
c'est l'inquiétude des parents d'élèves
pour qui le protocole sanitaire
annoncées restent trop strictes pour les
écoles primaires et les collèges
la distanciation physique ayant été
totalement levées en maternelle une
classe a à peu près en tout cas sur lui
en course a fait en élémentaire ça fait
cinquante mètres carrés de 50 mètres
carrés il faut mettre les élèves
promettent l'enseignant faut mettre les
tables promettent ils ont tous des
armoires dans les classes donc on ne
peut pas enlever les armoires il faut
laisser un sens de circulation dans la
classe donc on va pas beaucoup augmenté
le nombre d'enfants en fait c'est le
souci qui va avoir
bah oui peut-être deux pièces on va
passer à 17 ou 20 mai sur les classes de
on ne pourra jamais prendre tout le
monde et il ya beaucoup de classes de 29
et oui ça existe et c'est le problème
c'est que tout le monde ne pourra pas
reprendre
côté enseignants déplorent le temps trop
long entre l' annonce du président et la
livraison d'un protocole claires
publiées mercredi dans la soirée
ce qu'on voudrait c'est pour travailler
tranquillement pour travailler
tranquillement il faut arrêter de mettre
des protocoles qui épuise les équipes
dans leur réalisation et qui empêche
l'accueil effectifs des élèves
en plus de l'allègement de la
distanciation physiques de 4 mètres
carrés par personne à omettre d'écart
les enfants pourront accéder aux jeux
extérieurs et jouée par exemple au
ballon entre élèves d'une même classe et
les enseignants ne seront plus obligés
de porter un masque
sauf si la distance d'un mètre ne peut
être respectée autre annonce concernant
la phase iii du déconfinement toute la
france métropolitaine et en zone verte
et peut rouvrir ses restaurants même en
salle certains étaient en place dès
lundi comme ce restaurant italien de
montigny le bretonneux mathilde de demi
et aurélie oms en salle ou en terrasse
les restaurateurs peuvent à présent
reposer cette fameuse question
suite aux annonces des manuels macron
même si le temps n'est pas encore au
beau fixe
la réouverture des salles divise la
clientèle sera que c'est quand même plus
agréable de s'asseoir de se poser de
manger sur place
c'est une bête dehors je pense c'est à
dire libre partie nous manque que les
gestes barrières sont respectés la
distance et respectez donc ceux là il
n'y a pas de en terrasse ou intérieure
se passe pas un problème
surpris par les annonces du président ce
restaurateur de montigny le bretonneux a
eu à peine le temps de se préparer pour
la réouverture
il a rappelé dimanche soir c'est aux
salariés pour revenir travailler à temps
plein ce lundi matin
pour nous c'est un soulagement de
pouvoir ouvrir
on attendait depuis tellement longtemps
de retrouver un peu une vie normale
néanmoins quand même de d'ouvrir en
prévenant on peut s'arrêter n'aura pu
s'organiser mieux nous on travaille
essentiellement quasiment que des
produits frais donc pour
s'approvisionner c'est pas évident une
table sur deux est occupé par des
clients et sur ses deux salles une seule
est ouverte ce qui représente 40
couverts sur 80 depuis le 2 juin il a dû
investir pour pouvoir accueillir plus de
monde en terrasse va terrasse derrière
je peux mettre beaucoup de monde mais
comme nos clients ne savaient pas et que
la copropriété a nous a alloué sept
espaces et que le temps de d'acheter le
matériel parce que encore une fois quand
vous allez faire des achats pour une
terrasse vous n'avez pas forcément tout
l'équipement forcément notre activité
est très impacté
en tout cas on espère d'ici la fin
d'année retrouvez un écran
fonctionnement plutôt normal pour
rouvrir totalement les restaurateurs
devront respecter un protocole strict 10
clients maximum par table
rendre le port du masque obligatoire
pour se déplacer dans le restaurant et
espacer les tables d'un mètre mardi les
organisations médicales paramédicales et
ainsi que les collectifs ont manifesté
dans toute la france dans les yvelines
plusieurs actions ont été menées les
soignants se sont rassemblés à partir de
13 heures devant plusieurs hôpitaux
exemple à versailles à montrent la jolie
avec manon varaldo et michael et demi
d'euros forte mobilisation du personnel
soignant ce mardi 16 juin dans les
yvelines au centre hospitalier de
versailles andré mignot une centaine de
professionnels tous services confondus à
des filets suite à l'appel des syndicats
qu'ils se sont réunis devant la
structure à 13h en faisant beaucoup de
bruit
on va à tâtons récurrentes rappelé
l'importance de l'hôpital public et puis
les enjeux qui a autant de talent public
et je pense que là tous étaient
conscients de cela au travers de la
crise du coc vide et on souhaite que ce
qui a été initié avant la crise se
poursuivent après la crise de sorte à ce
que le public soit préservé même constat
à l'hôpital de mantes-la-jolie pendant
la période du coc vide 19 le personnel
soignant estime qu'il a prouvé son
engagement
parmi leurs revendications des moyens
supplémentaires pour travailler on a
plus de pied à perfusion n'a plus de 2
pousse seringue
on a plus de chaises roulantes et on
fait quoi pour travailler pour certains
collègues ils ont fait des bouts de
ficelle avec des sacs plastique en guise
de goût
ce qui a vraiment mis en évidence la
carence du système hospitalier à l'heure
actuelle deux clés 2015 on l'a perdu 109
lits d'hospitalisation et près de 250
postes
est ce qu'il ya eu une modification de
son action gouvernementale absolument
pas les soignants demande également une
revalorisation de salaire
l'intersyndicale réclame 300 euros pour
tous cette soignant le travail à
l'hôpital de mantes-la-jolie depuis 15
ans elle se mobilise avec le collectif
inter hôpitaux c'est investir dans la
santé des français
l'hôpital public il est indispensable
pour le bon fonctionnement de cet état
le privé ne me fait pas le même travail
que l'hôpital public que privé
sélectionne ses patients nous on
sélectionne pas on prend ton monde
les soignants attendent des réponses du
gouvernement d'autres mobilisations
devrait être organisée dans les
prochaines semaines dans les yvelines
le conseil d'administration de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental yvelines
hauts-de-seine se réunissent et mardi
pour l'élection de son nouveau président
après un hommage rendu à patrick
devedjian le nouveau président des
hauts-de-seine georges siffredi a été
élu à l'unanimité
pierre bédier quant à lui vice président
toujours convaincu par la fusion entre
les départements le pays travaille sur
un projet de plate forme
d'établissements et services pour
personnes en situation de handicap
psychique ou atteints d'autisme que j'ai
su qu'il était candidat à la succession
de patrick devedjian
de prendre aussi sa succession
l'établissement public
interdépartemental puisque c'était un
accord qui avait été passé avec patrick
devedjan les hauts-de-seine aller
jusqu'en mars 2021 et après on discutera
de tout à tout ce qu'on espère un
c'était ne pas avoir discuté que la
fusion soit fait pour succéder à patrick
devedjian qui était personnalité donc
pas évident ça vous met des réponses
étaient supplémentaire sur les épaules
mais je vois tout cela sereinement parce
que beaucoup de choses ont déjà été
faites et qu'avec le président bédié
nous entendons me très bien nous
connaissons depuis longtemps
mercredi ce devait être le premier jour
des épreuves du baccalauréat 2020 les
élèves auraient dû plancher sur la
mythique épreuve de philosophie
seulement avec la crise du colonel virus
l'examen a été repensé et tourné vers le
contrôle continu dans l'académie de
versailles comprenant les yvelines
l'essonne les hauts de seine et le val
d'oise ils sont plus de quarante et un
mille candidats en filière générale
concernés par cette cession 2020 un peu
spécial près de 14500 par le bac
technologique résultats attendus pour le
mardi 7 juillet jeudi c'était les 80 ans
de l'appel du général de gaulle du 18
juin en 1940 le général de gaulle
appelait les français à poursuivre le
combat contre l'allemagne nazie
et pour cet anniversaire de nombreuses
communes des yvelines ont commémoré
cette date avec des cérémonies le plus
souvent sans public à versailles
notamment devant le monument aux morts
de la seconde guerre mondiale le préfet
des yvelines jean jacques brot à lui
assisté à l'hommage à rambouillet
cérémonie également du côté de poissy
devant le buste de charles de gaulle
d'autres se sont tenues dans la soirée
comme à guyancourt et c'est aussi
l'occasion de se souvenir de ceux qui
ont résisté lors de la guerre de 39-45
le conseil départemental des yvelines
met en place des ressources pédagogiques
en ligne ainsi que le jeu éducatif
réseau conçu par les archives
départementales il permet de découvrir
comment fonctionner les réseaux
clandestins et prendre conscience des
risques encourus par les résistants
après une chute de 88% des ventes de
véhicules au mois d'avril d'après les
chiffres du comité des constructeurs
français d'automobiles le marché semble
rebondi
les établissements ouverts et les
clients sont de retour notamment pour
acheter des véhicules d'occasion exemple
avec une concession à plaisir par
nicolas landry un véritable rebond
d'activité dans cette concession
automobile des appels des contacts par
internet
l'activité a repris le 11 mai dans cet
établissement fermé pendant le
confinement
les clients sont vite revenus on a fait
sur quinze jours l'équivalent d'un mois
de commerce sur le mois de mai ça a été
ça a été assez fulgurant impressionnant
s'est même retrouvé avec un des clients
plusieurs clients sur la même voiture
on a eu un pic d'activité qui est de 30%
supérieur à ce qu'on a sur un mois de
mai habituels les véhicules d'occasion
ont eu le plus de succès dans cette
reprise le plan de relance du secteur
automobile annoncé par le président de
la république
un site à l'acquisition de véhicules
vers une aide de 7000 euros pour l'achat
d'un véhicule électrique et une prime de
2000 euros pour l'achat d'un véhicule
hybride où on a eu beaucoup beaucoup de
demandes par téléphone suite à cela
savoir si nos véhicules et éligibles
quels véhicules on pouvait proposer par
rapport à cela donc ça se prêtait très
bien avec l'actualité mini et bmw avec
la mini électrique ou des véhicules plus
récents comme le x3 hybride 6 1 re
démarrage est constatée dans cette
concession une reprise durable est
espéré sur les deux mois de confinement
l'établissement a perdu près de 80% de
son chiffre d'affaires dimanche 21 juin
c'est la fête de la musique événement
forcément particulier en ce contexte de
crise sanitaire qui ne pourra pas se
tenir dans des conditions normales
plusieurs communes ont décidé d'annuler
leurs festivités pour se conformer aux
gestes barrières certaines ont tout de
même décidé de maintenir des animations
avec le respect de la distanciation
physique maurepas vous donne rendez vous
à partir de 16h dans les commerces de la
ville pour des concerts à
magny-les-hameaux c'est une déambulation
musicale qui vous est proposé à 15h30
entre le musée et la granja blé fête de
la musique aux balcons et jardins à
plaisir les
libre cours à votre créativité musicale
depuis chez vous pour figurer dans la
programmation vous pouvez vous
rapprocher de la direction des affaires
culturelles
enfin versailles et coignières ont
choisi de diffuser des concerts en live
la fête de la musique c'est justement le
sujet de notre rubrique ça s'est passé
retour sur l'événement à guyancourt en
2012 et le public était nombreux
[Musique]
ambiance jazz ambiance groovy ambiance
funky ce soir à la batterie alors c'est
pas mal en guise d'introduction mais moi
je vous propose de passer tout de suite
à quelque chose de beaucoup plus
rock'n'roll le rock'n'roll c'est
justement le thème qu'a choisi blanc
revient bien et son équipe pour fêter la
musique et pourquoi leur fête de la
musique
j'entendais calais alors pourquoi le
choix de ce thème de la gauche
posez c'est parti
[Musique]
parce que nos groupes qui répètent ici
dans nos studios sont majoritairement du
groupe pop-rock langueur abattre 80%
sont clairement ça se ressent sur les
plateaux blanc or l'on propose ce soir
tu veux toujours beaucoup classic rock
je ne peux pas prendre eux aussi
savaient pensée de génération faut dire
qu'on touche vraiment aussi dans nos
studios une sorte de narration que le
rock
maintenant très anciens voilà la map
fait aussi son anniversaire aujourd'hui
autant de styles que d'interprète et
quand on demande aux spectateurs si le
roc leur évoque quelque chose
chacun y va de sa référente hendrix
et êtes plutôt dans les années 60-70 de
la musique qui bouge
la musique avec beaucoup d'instruments
la guitare électrique
[Musique]
ces lycées metallica volbeat les beatles
un plot to rolling stones aussi pour moi
parce que je suis pas une adepte
particulièrement de cette musique c'est
plutôt une époque
les années 70 la grande liberté les
barrières pour suis tombé et tout ça
ouais bon je pense que ça a le mérite
d'être clair en tout cas quel que soit
le style l'origine ou l'interprète
les spectateurs présents samedi soir à
la batterie ont eu l'occasion de s'en
mettre plein les oreilles écoutez
[Musique]
là
je pars
et
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de nous avoir suivis retour de
l'actualité locale dès lundi avec le 7-8
journal pour week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour
[Musique]